I will say it's really weird seeing him
with gray hair like really weird oh my
gosh Savannah Chrisley confirming time
spares no one even Todd Chrisley look
any family who faces a loved one going
to prison it's a very difficult
challenge the Chrisley Knows Best star
opens up on her unlocked podcast
detailing a recent visit to her dad
behind bars I know in my heart like who
my parents are roughly one month after
Todd and Julie Chrisley surrendered to
prison and I've been in the presence of
all these great churches but to be able
to say that I've never felt a presence
of Jesus more than I did in a prison
visiting room says a lot I think that I
I have raised thanking children and so I
for that I'm blessed even in that short
amount of time Savannah admits her dad's
already
different I will say it's really weird
seeing him with gray hair like really
weird I didn't have anyone it's already
gray yeah like you know he's definitely
used some color over the years and now
seeing Kim with gray hair I'm like oh my
gosh despite his new appearance
Savannah's faith and her parents who are
serving a combined 19-year sentence
remains unchanged I know in my heart
like who my parents are and that's what
brings me so much joy and in a way I'm
so blessed and grateful that all these
other people get to experience the love
of them yeah like they're in there and
they're with these people who are
struggling with like my mom's the mom
for those don't that haven't had a mom
my dad's a dad for those that haven't
had a father figure and so for me I'm
like you know what I'm blessed that they
get to be that for someone I've never
seen two people my parents be so
steadfast in their faith in the end the
truth will prevail may get harder before
it gets easier but we have faith
Savannah's feelings Echo their family
attorneys who's helping Todd and Julie
file an appeal before the February 22nd
deadline if Todd and Julie could share a
message with the world what do you think
they'd want them to know I think they'd
want folks to know that they are the
same people they've always been that
they didn't do these things and that
they're going to fight to get their name
clear
between visits Savannah's got quite the
commute Todd's Federal facility is in
Pensacola Florida meanwhile Julie's 655
miles away from him in Kentucky whether
this appeal works or not they're still
coming out with a story going in day one
are is the fight to get out already
started absolutely I think that anybody
who's facing a prison term and is in a
contested case with the government is
going to try to fight you know well
before they end up behind those bars and
will continue to fight when they are I
think that optimism is well placed this
trial was riddled with heirs and we
expect the appeals court to see that